[Music]
what is that
[Music]
haven't made fun i have to laugh or cry
let's go with the first clip i'm scared
hey guys
so after my last videos i got a lot of
questions about trying an english
breakfast so today i am going to make
you some british eggs
yeah so first you want to get your eggs
out of the fridge i mean you can't go
wrong
make mistakes right add a little whipped
cream
whisk it together actually you're going
to scramble this
and that's how you cook british eggs
really
we need to ask all the english friends
out there is that how you do it guys
because
i don't believe you do that i mean she
looks happy
but maybe she has never eaten what she
cooked because i would be very unhappy
if you serve me this for breakfast
he's making a pizza in there oh
oh my god wow
that's a burnt pizza i've never had
burnt pizza in my life
sorry
[Laughter]
he's trying he's trying to save the
pizza
we're in the bay in the rubbish
paintbrush
did you see this guy is trying to save
the pizza
where is he going with the pizza where
is he going oh my god
i'm crying please don't play this video
already everything is wrong already i
can tell
everything is wrong oh
you can't serve this pasta when you oh
oh
no
first he cooked the pasta the wrong way
then he baked it
and then he put what is that
ah look at his face look at his face
look at his face
look at his face look how proud he is
he's gonna spend
a lot of time in the toilet this guy let
me tell you he's going to spend
all day in the toilet don't do that to
these people please
life is too short we need to have
amazing food every single day
another pizza becomes scared what is
this
oh that's a pizza that's another pizza
what do you do with this honestly what
do you do with this pizza
just return it don't even try to cook it
please
i think it's a calzone yeah maybe that's
what they're trying to do i mean you
purchase a pizza
a chicken pizza by the way and then you
find a calzone inside
in italy we never had chicken pizza no
pineapple pizza
i say one thing there is there are so
many pizzas to try
before you get to the chicken pizza you
can have prosciutto you can have
margarita you can have four cheeses you
can have potato pizzas
sausages mushrooms why why you pick
chicken
pick other pizzas first and then you
pick the chicken
it is easy to find pineapple pizza
everywhere i've tried it
but you just can't put pineapple on the
pizza it just doesn't
can you put pineapple and sauce together
can you do that
can you put pineapple and sauce tomorrow
please try and
get a piece of pineapple dip it in in
the sauce
and eat it you tell me if that's nice
i mean this is funny what he's doing but
why are you doing this to the pastor why
are you doing this
it is funny and sad at the same time
i don't know if i have to laugh or cry
oh look at his face a round of applause
because even
you have big bowls my friend for doing
this how can you do that to the pasta
all right so this lady is cooking the
pasta i'm assuming yes
okay maybe she's trying to kill a spa
spider or something she must have seen a
spider
oh my gosh she tried to put the pasta
on the wall because i don't know why but
people think that the way to check if
the pasta is ready
is by by throwing the pasta on the wall
and if it gets stuck on the wall the
pasta is ready
that's no right that's that's not true
you taste the pasta with your mouth
that's the only way
you